are you actually with marvel do you have
some sort of credentials what's your
secret password
he was really like excited to be back
you could tell that like it really meant
a lot to him they both cared so deeply
about the characters
what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and today marvel studios
released on their official marvel
entertainment youtube channel
tom holland and zendaya talking about
what it was like to work with toby
mcguire andrew garfield alfred molina
william the foe and they are talking
about the ending and the relationship
between mj and peter as well and you can
kind of see the relationship between tom
holland and zendaya on screen as well
but i thought it would be really cool
for us all to give it a watch because i
know everybody's been waiting for tom
holland and everybody to open up about
what it's like to work together
yesterday there was an interview with
all three spider-man i'll link that up
above and in the description down below
but let's go ahead and watch tom holland
and zendaya talk about angie garfield
and toby mcguire what was it like to
work with
benedict cumberbatch okay awesome i love
benedict it's always a pleasure to share
the screen with him so it was a lot of
fun to do it again he's very sweet very
like just just a nice guy to be around
and also was really cool i actually have
a picture of him like skateboarding
around set oh yeah i was like i just
love seeing doctor strange skateboarding
skateboarding
john from rose's freaking girl
he is like the coolest guy and so funny
so funny such great comedic timing
challenge
we had so much fun working with charlie
like it's really interesting doing a
scene between two superheroes that has
no like real superhero stuff in it apart
from the bit where he catches the brick
uh but it was awesome
you weren't there for that well you were
there for that i was there for behind
the scenes watching you guys oh yeah but
i didn't get to leave against the
beginning
but it was great i loved working with
charlie
molina
the coolest one of the funniest people
i've ever really like he really makes
you love you love alfred yeah i had a
really good time with alfred
fricking i've never worked with an actor
who was able to give a director so many
options
well he has this one speech in the film
where he's talking about this sort of
peter's kind of existential crisis and
he
scared the skills
and he gave us so many different options
he must have done it 30 times the
coolest thing is that everyone's so
lovely and then they just play like
these very evil pairs yeah
and they're so he's so good at just like
just being like a lovely like you know
hey how are you all good and then
you know whoa
toby mcguire let's get it toby was so
funny
like so cool like we had so many little
in jokes that came up from working with
toby
definitely naturally wow
team of g man like he was so funny and
like
he was really like excited to be back
you could tell that like it really meant
a lot to him um and him putting the suit
on again and us getting back together
like it was so funny that first day
i was like nervous for you yeah i was
stressed because i was like we we had to
do like a rehearsal and and me and jacob
felt like your parents
like dropping you over kindergarten for
the first day and it's like i hope the
other kids like him
you know and like i hope he doesn't come
back crying so we were just there and
like i was taking pictures of you guys
so that you could have it and it was so
cute you have some amazing pictures i
want to see that picture i do
andrew garfield all right before we jump
into the indycar phone i just want to
say that in the interview that they put
out yesterday with all three spider-man
they said that their first time like
together was they just put on the suits
and they just were like jumping around
together like that's all they were doing
was they literally all cause you gotta
imagine it takes a lot to put on those
suits they're like spandex and then they
all got together and they were just
jumping around and how cool would it
have been to be there for that
i wish i was there for that all right
andrew garfield
andrew garfield the legend himself
legend himself it was such a privilege
to work with him like he's such a lovely
guy they both cared so deeply about the
characters
and
what their characters what their their
journey had been as spider-man and it
was so beautiful to see all of you guys
connect on that and be able to talk to
each other about such a special
experience that very few people have
been able to like dawn the suit three
people so i don't know it was great to
see how much you guys all really cared
and yeah kind of had each other's back
it was really sweet it's like a
brotherhood oh brother
i love it so much
tom what does it mean to be big
spiderman has changed my life it's been
incredible the roller coaster from the
moment i got on to the moment we've got
off has just been absolutely amazing and
i wouldn't have changed a single moment
of it you know
this film really is a celebration of
three generations of cinema and i was
delighted to kind of be at the helm and
be the captain of the ship um
which was awesome uh so it's been
incredible it's been honestly
the best thing that's ever happened to
me
time to talk about some
spoilers zendaya how do you think peter
and mj's relationship has helped her
grow emotionally
well there's a few things i think that
peter
um
helps to
uh melt her a little bit and like break
the shell that she's had to build in
order to protect herself from the world
because i think she's probably had a
a tough life you know and doesn't have
many people she feels that she can trust
and rely on and peter has now become one
of those people and she doesn't want to
lose him um and i think because she does
what she does losing she loses
she doesn't want to i know it's horrible
awful i just really felt good saying
that that's the spoiler and getting that
out yeah
she doesn't she doesn't want to lose
this person that really
i think
has allowed her to feel more and more
like herself and more and more confident
in who she is
um and loves her exactly for all the
quirks and things that make her who she
is i don't know all in the same token i
think because he's going through so much
she now
takes on
his positivity that maybe he's losing a
little bit so he takes on
a more negative nihilistic outlook i
mean rightfully so because he's been
through so much and she's the one that's
trying to uh
yeah it's like a role reversal yeah
[Music]
what do you want to say to fans about
the end of i'm sorry i wanted them to
have a happy ending i wanted them to
have a happy ending i wanted them just
to go to college
we're feeling good we're proud of the
movie it would have been so nice for
them to go to college and just swing off
into the sunset but unfortunately
you know
uh
this is the way it is it doesn't happen
all right so
real quick right there
he says but we're still here so in the
interview that came out yesterday
he's like oh i don't know if i'm gonna
play spider-man again but kevin feige
already came out and so did amy pascal
of sony and they already said like
yeah we're working on the next
spider-man film the mcu spider-man film
and tom holland's already talked about
doing the next film so we don't know
when they filmed these we don't know
when they filmed the interview last time
but in this one he says we're still here
and to me it sounded like he meant
well we're still here as in like we're
going to be doing more films there's
still hope for peter and nj to get
together in future movies because if you
know between you and i i don't think the
spell is 100 effective i think
eventually mj will remember peter and
yes he put everything aside but uh you
know he did that to help his friends but
i think eventually he's going to get his
mj and uh i really hope that andrew
garfield gets his mj as well
zedaya what's going on with peter parker
and spider-man knowing him what is going
on what is going on with your
um well in this film
unfortunately due to our previous film
uh mysterio has now revealed his
identity to the world the world knows
that revealed revealed
i got you
i didn't she meant to say revealed
i want to see these two like
together in real life like not on camera
like just see how they actually are
together their relationships probably
got to be pretty funny
tom what's up with mj in the film
mj is
falling head over heels in love for
peter
not not lying that's true that's true
she is he's a bit hesitant though
he didn't think it was the right choice
but then he's still pining after liz
from the first movie
um
okay time out i feel like they're
talking about their actual relationship
in real life right here like i genuinely
think that that's what they're talking
about here
and i can totally see zendaya being the
one that's like yes let's go let's go
but tom being kind of like oh maybe
let's take it a little slower just
because of the film and everything like
that
you could totally see this is how they
are together
who makes you laugh the most
everyone really i mean you make me laugh
a lot
um pretty funny jacob makes me laugh
jacob's easy to make but here's the
thing
but here's the thing i don't think we're
like attempting to make each other laugh
so much as laughing at each other and
then we make the jokes and then it gets
funnier and funnier yeah yeah the jokes
are always born out of one of us doing
something stupid well that was really
really cool it's cool to see tom
hollands and deya talking about tobey
maguire andrew garfield alfred molina
willem dafoe this movie was just
insane and the journey was really cool
too
wondering if they were gonna be in it or
not even though
you know i was the one who talked about
how they are in it there was still like
a point zero one percent of doubt going
into it like oh my gosh are they in it
but it was fantastic let me know what
you think about this in the comments
down below and again let me know what
you thought of spider-man no way home
since the you know the hype has kind of
died down now since you know everybody's
for the most part have seen it
do you still love it is it still your
favorite let me know what you think in
the comments down below don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos for live updates you can follow
me on instagram and twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof